I know your side it's a long story that
I'm going to explain everything to you
forehead I do have to ask you Mila
what would you do if tomorrow you woke
up and found out that Ashton was a spy I
feel like I knew it their lives why I
married you
now what do we do do you think he could
be a good was he that still or yes would
he just tell it he had home he's so
smart I wouldn't put it past him if like
10 years so no he's like babe I got a
slice and they're like yeah ok I totally
believe it I knew I knew while we were
filming something's up he also has
multiple jobs like not everything adds
up where I'm like what do you really
what is this office you claim to go to
and why are there are many different
locations of this so he's here somewhere
I question it you're welcome to ask
please tell me that you guys really are
friends now and that this relationship
is gonna continue it is real I'm sorry
what you see is real
unfortunately suffer I can't touch her
professional faith and she's got she's
you know we got stuff all over yeah
hours hours hours of work that's the
word that we didn't do we've got a
sitting right now meaning you're the
boss
and yet you have not sacrificed one
ounce of femininity that is the Beyonce
of the government
[Music]
[Applause]